Given that x+2 is greater than 5,
x must be greater than 3.
You use the same procedure to solve a
linear inequality for x that you do for
a linear equation,
with one exception that we will show.
So for the inequality x+2 > 5, we just
treat the inequality like an equal sign.
Just like we saw with linear equations,
we're trying to isolate x.
Here we can do that by
subtracting 2 from both sides.
And we get x+0 > 5-2,
which we simplify to x > 3.
When you're done isolating the variable
on one side, you should graph
the solution set on a number line
since it's a range of values.
Our number line should look like this.
The end point is 3.
Our circle is open because 3 is
not part of the solution set.
And our arrow points to the right,
towards positive infinity.